[Music]
welcome back so in the last lecture we
cooked up a simple linear regression
example with one input variable a and
one outcome variable B where we knew the
answer we knew the model was linear
relating a and B we knew the slope and
from noisy data we saw that we could
recover a pretty good approximation of
that slope using the least squares best
fits from the pseudo inverse of the a
matrix okay and now what we're gonna
show you is how you can do this for
higher dimensional data sets where
instead of just having a single factor a
that's the input to your model you might
have multiple factors a 1 a 2 a 3 that
could all be used to build a prediction
of of your outcome variable B so maybe I
have four or five or six different
things I measure a you know different
variables I measure and I want to build
a linear regression model from those
five or six variables to this outcome B
okay again this could be demographic
information age sex weight diet things
like that and B could be a risk of a
heart attack okay something like that
and again you can do that by collecting
these measurements in these column
vectors of a of those input factors and
measurements in this column vector of B
of the outcome risk for a number of
individual patients those would be the
rows of this equation and you would
solve for the best fit slope X of that
model using this pseudo inverse here of
the a matrix times the outcome vector B
okay and you can do this in a simple
example for 1d in this next example
we're going to load this Portland cement
data so it's in this this data folder
under hauled ingredients that CSV and
hauled heat death CSV this is a built in
example in MATLAB that we have converted
into into a CSV file and you can load
here and the idea is when you mix
concrete it gets hotter okay it
generates heat and so what this data set
consists of are 13 experiments where you
have
essentially four possible ingredients
that you can mix up to make cement okay
so this has four columns and each row is
one of thirteen experiments okay so I
take a particular mixture of these four
ingredients I mix them up and I measure
how much heat was generated in that
experiment that would be the first entry
of this B this B vector would be the
amount of heat from those ingredients
then the next row would be another
experiment where I mix up a different
mixture of ingredients for cement and I
see what heat that generates and so on
and so forth
and what you might want to do is build a
model so that if you had a new mixture
of ingredients you could predict how
much heat would be generated by that
cement mixture as it as it hardens and
so what we're gonna do is we're gonna
approximate we're gonna find the best
fit slope X that maps these four
features into this outcome heat variable
here okay and we're gonna in principle
that would allow us that model would
allow us to predict the heat generation
from future mixtures that we haven't
actually tried out yet okay so very
simple again we're gonna base this on
the pseudo-inverse we're gonna compute
the SVD we're gonna compute the
pseudo-inverse
to find this best fit slope X and then
what we're gonna do is we're going to
plot I just do this one more time we're
going to plot the actual heat data so
this is probably in like temperature on
the y axis for these these thirteen
different ingredient mixtures these
thirteen different experiments that we
have and what you see is that the the
true heat data here in white actually
matches very nicely the approximation of
our model this regression model in blue
okay so this shows that you can build a
pretty good model that captures most of
the mapping from the ingredient mixture
to the heat generated by curing that
Simmons now I should point out that this
is I'm being a little dodgy here so in
general it's a bad idea
to take all of your data to train a
model and then to plot and show that you
can fit the training data with your
model that's kind of cheating and maybe
I over fit the training data maybe maybe
I over fit the slope of that line to the
particular training data and so what you
would actually do in practice generally
is you would take maybe only the first
ten experiments and you'd use those
first ten experiments to build a model
for X and then you test that model on
the remaining three experiments to see
if it can work on a holdout data set
that you've withheld to test on okay
this is the the basis of all of
statistical learning and machine
learning is splitting your data into a
training section and a test section and
holding out some of your data so you can
test your model and not have it be
biased so really really important of
course I'm completely glossing over that
here but I want you to be aware that in
reality you would actually have to hold
out some of your data for testing to see
if your model really did a good job okay
we're going to talk a lot more about
this in our book data-driven science and
engineering many many chapters are going
to be devoted to machine learning and
how you validate and cross validate your
data by holding out holding out or
validate your model by holding out some
of your data okay thank you